a CBS News investigation finds thousands
of tons of dangerous coal ash are being
brought into the mainland us this comes
as the Trump administration weakens
regulations on coal plants coal ash is a
leftover material from burning coal and
is linked to cancer and other diseases
CBS News tracked the massive payload
being shipped from Puerto Rico to
Jacksonville Florida CBS News chief
investigative correspondent Jim Axelrod
has been following this Jim good morning
good morning Americans have felt the
impacts of coal ash for decades studies
show it can be harmful to both people
and the environment the AES corporation
is transporting coal ash to a landfill
in the mainland United States the cargo
this ship heading toward the port of
Jacksonville Florida is hauling is coal
ash a toxic by-product when coal was
burned to generate electricity the
Mississippi Enterprise it arrives in
Florida with its boatload of coal ash
begins its journey right here 1,200
miles away and why llaman Puerto Rico
this is a conveyor belt loading the ash
from a coal fueled power plant half a
mile away onto the boat the AES power
plant generates 300,000 tons of coal ash
each year and there is no disposal
facility on the island the people of
Puerto Rico don't want the coal ash so
they passed a law that it cannot be
stored here the coal ash waste overflows
out of the conveyer system lawyer and
activist Ruth Santiago has been battling
AES to provide better safeguards in
disposing its coal ash you see this
barge full of this stuff that everybody
says is toxic and it's pulling into
Florida and then going to other
communities for disposal what's your
warning to them they should not allow
the import of the toxic coal ash to
their communities exposure to coal ash
is what concerns dr is valle de rosario
a professor of environmental chemistry
at the university of puerto rico
Kolas
chemically speaking how dangerous it's
full of toxic material arsenic selenium
chromium six you'll begin seeing
respiratory problems higher levels of
cancer multiple studies show that
exposure to coal ash is hazardous plenty
of people in Tennessee will agree with
that on December 22nd 2008 a dike
ruptured at the Tennessee Valley
Authority power plant in the town of
Kingston spilling more than a billion
gallons of coal ash before the spill yes
in December of 2008 were you healthy yes
it's in perfect health I didn't know not
medical problems
Elmer Lao spent two years as a cleanup
worker without the necessary protective
gear to prevent him from breathing in
the coal ash says his wife Donna he's
part of an ongoing lawsuit against the
company that hired him what did he look
like when he would come in the front
door it looked like it was white and it
was clay and it was nasty
mud but it wasn't mud it was the co
[ __ ] named Lao went from an active
and healthy man to suffering from
Addison's disease lupus arthritis gout
asthma and an enlarged prostate the
Obama administration in 2015 established
new federal regulations for coal ash
storage including monitoring of nearby
groundwater as well as its disposal we
have ended the war on beautiful clean
call regulations the Trump
administration's EPA headed by former
coal industry lobbyist Andrew wheeler
and I'm not at all ashamed of the work
that I did for the coal company is in
the process of weakening when I tell you
that there are tens of thousands of tons
maybe even more of coal ash coming in to
the mainland United States from Puerto
Rico does that concern you
it sure does my nominee Gina McCarthy
Gina McCarthy was the EPA Administrator
when the 2015 regular
Asians we're implementing rulemaking is
supposed to protect people what I would
call a rollback and a weakening of
protections is is focused more on making
the industrial pollutant not have to pay
to clean up their pollution and much
less about the protecting the
disadvantaged communities that
government is supposed to protect the
EPA said in a statement quote a majority
of 2015 rules remain in place and are
being implemented on schedule
Andrew wheeler declined our request for
an on-camera interview an Aes said in a
statement quote we comply with all local
and federal regulations and furthermore
the EPA classifies coal ash as a non
hazardous material you can read the full
statement on our website CBS news.com of
investigation yeah we get about a
quarter of our electricity in this
country from coal you could replace that
source or do something to deal with what
results from that coal processing can't
you neither though but to hear that it's
coming in from someplace else
and then the former you know EPA person
say their concern is I don't get him out
yeah thank you Jim